surveillance video shows Pedro Lozano
walking around the valet at the El
Cortez lizano lights up a cigarette and
smokes it lying down on a bench moments
later security officer Randy Lyons walks
up to Lozano Lozano then rushes at him
pushing him to the ground what happens
next is out of the camera's view when he
pushed him Randy fell backwards and hit
his head on the concrete which uh
caused an immediate brain bleed lions
and Elizabeth McDowell were married for
11 years
on September 26 2021 McDowell drove to
the El Cortez after her husband's shift
went to pick him up from work and he
wasn't coming out he wasn't coming out
he wasn't coming out or I'm like what's
going you know what's going on
paramedics rushed Lions to the hospital
he'd be there for months until McDowell
made the difficult decision of taking
her husband off life support and I said
and I'm going to miss you but this is
the best thing for you and he squeezed
my hand like he understood court records
revealing Lozano took a plea deal on a
charge of involuntary manslaughter
putting him in prison for up to eight
years as the news now investigators
first reported metro police records show
officers have arrested Lozano 49 times
since 2008. police most recently
remanding him into custody in August on
battery and vehicle theft charges he was
always lucky up until now now more than
a year year after the incident that led
to her husband's death McDowell believes
her husband knew it was his time time
with the man she loves stolen with a
simple push I don't hate him
but I can't forgive him
now the prison sentence for that
involuntary manslaughter charge is one
to four years but because of lion's age
remember he was 67 Lozano agreed to
serve double that so he will serve
between two and eight years ultimately
though a judge will decide his sentence
that between those years there in
December